hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar using metabolic analysis to
optimize bioprocess conditions
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by biolog
to learn more visit biolog.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to not welcome our speaker
Stacy Montgomery
senior director of marketing at biolab
Stacy you may not begin your
presentation
thank you Matt and thanks to everyone
joining us for this webinar on how
phenotype microarray technology is used
to optimize bioprocessing
two important aspects of optimization
are the development selection and
characterization of production strains
and how to develop optimal growth
conditions to produce the highest yield
possible
in the next few slides I'll show you how
the technology Works to provide a
comprehensive Global picture of your
production cell lines and how you can
use this technology in different stages
of development
there are many ways to take a
comprehensive or Global look at cellular
properties the issue is that these
transcriptomic or proteomic approaches
often show many changes at this
transcription or translation level but
there may be Downstream modifications or
processes that result in no discernible
effect on the cell so this means there's
an enormous amount of data to sift
through to find what is actually
meaningful and actionable so while they
result in massive amounts of data it can
be difficult to determine how those
changes actually affect a cell
so we've taken a different approach and
instead focused on cellular phenotyping
using a universal respiration reporter
that we can link to many different
compounds or conditions to get a
functional metabolic readout so we have
a series of Redux reporter dies that
allow us to link cellular respiration to
our compounds of Interest or different
conditions if the organism can utilize
the compound or respire in the presence
of components in the well they respire
they produce in ADH and that nadh can
then be used to convert our colorless
tetrazolium dye into a visible purple
color
so by looking at expressed cellular
Properties or phenotypes we're
eliminating much of the noise and can
focus on properties that are
biologically relevant to the cells of
Interest
the platform for all our assays is a
standard 96 well microtider plate each
well contains a different substrate or
an inhibitor along with our Universal
respiration reporter and if the
organisms can respire under this
condition The Well turns a visible
purple color that's non-reversible under
physiological conditions
for bacterial cells we have a series of
20 plates the top 10 plates are focused
on metabolic conditions where we look at
Carbon metabolism nitrogen metabolism
phosphorus sulfur osmotic and ionic
effects pH effects and then the second
set of plates at the bottom are chemical
sensitivity assays
the easiest way to think about what
we're doing is that each well is testing
for the presence or absence of a known
biochemical pathway
these are not random chemicals that we
used because they were inexpensive
stable easy to Source they were all
designed to interrogate a specific
biochemical pathway known to be present
in bacterial cells or a particular
condition such as optimal pH ability to
withstand salt Etc
the same thing is true for the inhibitor
panels we have a wide range of
Inhibitors with different mechanisms of
action so it's like we're poking the
cell in different places to see how it
responds to all those different insults
these assays are very simple to run and
consist of the phenotype microarray
plates the omnilog incubator reader and
software that's designed to interpret
the results so this is an example of a
typical experiment where we're
inoculating two plates with different
cell types so you can think of it as a
wild type versus a mutant strain or it
could be untreated Cells versus cells
treated with a particular compound we're
interested in but we inoculate our
plates one type labeled in red another
tech labeled in green place it into the
omnilog system it takes a Time point
every 15 minutes and then we get the the
plates with the Peaks showing the
phenotypic activity
the software then allows you to Overlay
those particular curves for the
different cell types and everywhere you
see yellow the cells are the same if you
see a red Peak or a green Peak it means
there's been a change in phenotype
between the two strains that you're
comparing
as I mentioned these are kinetic curves
for each well we're looking at and we're
looking at respiration over time and
then we can investigate the lag the
slope or the maximum response for each
substrate or test condition
this technology can be used for two
important aspects of bioprocess
development strain development and
selection of clones as well as
optimization of culture conditions for
best yield and we'll look at those two
aspects of the technology
the typical methods for process
development are slow and inefficient so
on the left side of the screen we
typically start with the production
strain modify that strain creating
daughter cell lines with better
production traits we then choose the
Clones that we're interested in and
manipulate the growth conditions such as
the media the pH different conditions
and then we screen a large number of
those clones for increased yield and
Tighter so this is this iterative circle
where we start with the strain
mutagenize it select clones measure
their tighter then we grow under
multiple feed conditions measured the
tighter again and if you get lucky we
proceed to scale up if not lucky we
start over so this is a process that
oftentimes gets repeated over and over
again
so let's review a few different kinds of
experiments that can be used to analyze
or compare your strains this first one
is a typical phenotype microarray
comparison of two strains it's a wild
type
mg1655 E coli strain and a mutant that
we've developed by transposon
mutagenesis in this case we've inserted
tn10 which carries a tetracycline
resistance Gene and we've inserted that
into the mall F Gene and what we see
when we compare the wild type to the
mutant in this experiment is we see that
we've lost the ability to utilize
maltose sugars as we expected and we can
also see that we gained resistance to
tetracycline and confirm our genetic
construct another thing we can see by
looking at this is we can see that we
didn't have any off-target effects
this is a more interesting example of
mutating a regulatory Gene in this case
we've interrupted the oxyar gene by
inserting a canomycin resistance
cassette so the oxyar gene that we've
mutated here is a global transcriptional
regulator of the oxidative stress
response and we can see that this
mutation affects a variety of cellular
phenotypes and this is a very
interesting example of being able to
globally or comprehensively screen your
cells if you're dealing with a
regulatory Gene sometimes it's hard to
predict what other genes this is
affecting so in this way we can see that
we've mutated our Gene our oxy-argin we
can see that we've introduced
aminoglycoside resistance and we can see
a whole range of changes as a result of
This Global transcriptional regulator
sometimes there's a need to discern the
differences between two closely related
strains in this case we're comparing two
strains of the same species a pathogenic
E coli o157 as compared to
mg1655 and people have understood that
0157 behaves differently from typical
lab strains of E coli for a long time in
this example everywhere you see a black
box the software is flagging a
significant difference between these two
strains
so experiments like this can be really
useful to determine changes in strains
due to phenotypic drift for example if
something feels off about your
production strain you can use these
types of experiments to detect what
those changes might be and then later
you can also use this as a very
comprehensive QC test to ensure the
strain that you're working with today
that you'll be using behaves exactly
like the strain that you were using two
years ago
so how do we correlate these color
changes in Wells to the amount of
function and figure out exactly what's
going on with our strains so let's take
a look at the omnilog software and see
what the options are
so the omnilog PM software is linked to
the Kyoto Encyclopedia of genes and
genomes or The Keg database and so we
can click on a single will on a plate
and the software will tell us what the
compound is in the well along with the
mechanism of action in this case we can
see I've clicked on a well A3 in PM
plate one and I can see that this is
inacetyl d-glucosamine and it's a carbon
Source One More click and it will show
me the molecular structure of that
compound
another click and I can get to the
enzymatic conversion and the products of
that conversion
another click and we can get to the
enzyme that catalyzes the conversion and
another click we've got the amino acid
sequence and the nucleotide sequence of
the gene for that enzyme
So within moments we can get to this end
result which is a pathway analysis at
our fingertips
so to summarize we looked at the
technology and how it can help us
develop select and characterize clones
with useful properties now we can look
at how it can also be used to determine
optimal conditions for growth of our
cell line
so once we've selected our specific
clones it's time to optimize growth
conditions we can now take our
prospective cell lines and determine the
optimal carbon Source nitrogen Source PH
range just by inoculating the proper
plates and incubating overnight this is
much more efficient than performing
Shake flask studies for each individual
compound or condition on multiple clones
so in this way in an overnight
experiment we could actually test 1920
conditions for each of the individual
clones
the goal is to find Optimal culture
conditions as early as possible and this
is some work that was shared by Nigel
mountie when he was at Dow agriscience
and his goal was to determine optimal
conditions for the development of a new
product so he was looking for carbon
sources that supported growth and in
addition to measuring carbon Source
utilization he also tested the titer of
the product in each well those Wells
that demonstrated a decrease in titer
were labeled in green and those that had
an increased tighter were labeled as
purple and what he found was culture
conditions that support the best growth
don't always result in the highest yield
of product so we need to find the
optimal carbon source and conditions for
growth but also for optimal yield in
addition while we're doing this we can
look at alternative carbon sources that
may be less expensive and once we get to
scale up does this could end up saving
us millions of dollars in production
costs
now we'll take a look at an experiment
where a client wanted us to examine
their production strain along with
several daughter cell lines and provide
input on optimal growth conditions so we
ran their parental strain in our lab and
three of their daughter's cell lines on
the PM or phenotype microarray metabolic
panels one through ten
so when we tested the parental strain
and looked at the Baseline metabolic
response what we saw was a little bit
surprising because it was pretty
non-reactive if you look at the PM
panels labeled three four five six seven
and eight you can see that there weren't
a lot of positive reactions but
we found out upon reviewing the data was
that the client's production strain
actually required leucine for growth
this need was unknown to the client but
made sense based on the formulation of
media that had been shown to be reactive
with this strain so they were dealing
with leucineox troph
the client wanted us to continue testing
the daughter cell lines to find out more
metabolic information if we could so we
found that all the daughter cell lines
when we compared them showed increased
sensitivity to Salt so we exported the
data and compared it side by side in a
graphical format
and you can see easily that the daughter
cell lines had become more sensitive to
Salt than the parental strain so our
observations for the client were that
the parental strain and outer cell lines
were all leucine oxotropes and all three
daughter cell lines were more sensitive
to sodium chloride concentrations so
they need to include leucine in the
production media and manage their salt
concentrations
the examples I've shown you so far have
been in bacterial production strains but
the technology also works for yeast and
filamentous fungi and this is an example
of how a single microplate was used to
look at Carbon Source utilization
secondary metabolite production
antimicrobial properties and they
actually used it to de-replicate their
culture collection so this is work that
was done by Maya sing it why at the
number of years ago using a single FF
micro plate that was originally designed
to identify fungi to the genus and
species level
what he did with the plate he took his
culture um they don't tell us what it is
in the paper they don't tell us what
they're trying to produce but you can
guess from these experiments that he's
looking for production of a secondary
metabolite that inhibits Candida
albicans
so what he did was take his strain of
Interest
inoculate the FF microplate and incubate
it then he read it on a standard Plate
Reader to see which carbon sources in
that plate supported growth of his
organism
for those substrates that supported
growth he then scaled up into one liter
Shake flasks and measured the target
metabolite
he also took the supernatants from the
FF microplate and then used those to
test against a lawn of candida albicans
to see if there was antimicrobial
activity in the supernatant
what he found was that Genta bios and
diffractos supported the highest levels
of growth
but on his scatter plot where he was
measuring the compound of interest and
the shake flasks with the substrates
that were best for growth the highest
result was obtained with sucrose and L
ramnose not fructose or Genta bios
and when he tested those supernatants
from the FF microplate for antimicrobial
activity with candida albicans sucrose
and ramnose were the substrates that led
to the highest inhibition so we can see
from these experiments that the
preferred carbon Source can be decoupled
from the carbon source that will allow
for the highest yield or tighter of our
product of Interest
so I've shown you how the technology can
be used for all types of microbial cells
for clone selection characterization and
determining optimal growth conditions I
also want to mention that we have the
same technology optimized for mammalian
cells as well so it's same basic
technology but the compounds and
protocols were optimized for
interrogating mammalian cell lines
I've covered a couple of use cases on
strain development and characterization
as well as optimization of culture
conditions leading to higher yields but
we've also seen our technology used in
novel ways for a lot of other
applications
so I've placed a link to a publication
database on this slide so I would
encourage you to go to this link and
look at the Publications you can sort
them by organism type application
product type so it's a great resource
that can also be sorted based on
countries or location of the authors so
it's a great resource for you to use and
with that I'll take questions
yes
thank you Stacy for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question today
number one can you use this technology
with other reporters such as gfp
yes you can so our Omni log instrument
can't read fluorescence or
chemiluminescence but you can the plates
are set up such that you can add dye if
you want it put it in the Omni log and
read the purple color formation so do
the metabolic respiration you could also
have if there was a green fluorescence
protein or another reporter you could
read those on another Plate Reader so
they will work together
okay thank you
next question is it possible to order
custom plates where we can choose only
the compounds we're interested in
question so we have done some special
pilot projects for specific customers
um but at this point in time it's it's
really
a process where a person would have to
order at least 100 plates of that type
maybe even more before we could take a
project on like that so I would say it
may be possible the best thing to do is
to send an email to info dialogue.com
and a representative will get back with
you and could discuss whether it's
possible
thank you Stacy
next question
how can I find out what compounds are
present in each plate
okay if you go to the website and look
under the products Tab and you go to
phenotype microarrays microbial you'll
see that
um there are buttons you can press for
the
phenotype microarray plate match one
through ten then there's another button
for phenotype microarray plate Maps 11
through 20 then there's a 20 through 25
21 through 25 for yeast and fungal
inhibitor plates
um same thing when you if you want to
look at mammalian
assays they're plate maps for those two
okay
question
number four we just got how many plates
can the omnilog hold
so it can hold 50 microplates
um for an experiment so you'll end up
with an enormous amount of data in a
single overnight experiment
thank you
hold on to the next question here would
this work with microbiomes or mixed
communities rather than pure cultures
yes absolutely so it's it's very
interesting there are a lot of people
that are currently
um working with microbiomes and looking
at the functional
um analysis of the community rather than
the genetic analysis so
um I would really for that if you're
interested in microbiome analysis I
would encourage you to go to the website
to the publication database and search
microbiome and it will pull up all the
recent papers of what people have done
um with these plates
yeah a couple questions her left the
next one have you seen any examples
where the diet self interfered with the
growth of your organism
it's possible that the dye could be
toxic
um you know we haven't tested every cell
line we've certainly tested
um you know
thousands of different cell lines with
technology but you know it does there
can be situations where the dye could
interfere one place it can be
problematic is working with anaerobic
um cells and so then what we typically
have customers do is not use the the
redox die and then look at growth
instead and so they're going to read it
on a separate Plate Reader and look for
turbidity in each well
okay great well looks like we have one
more question for today Stacy
uh the last question here which
mammalian cell line have you applied
this technology for
we've done a lot of different cell lines
obviously
um chose cells Colo cells there there
are a number of those so um if you go to
our website and just look under
mammalian
um
phenotype microarrays you'll see
examples and lists of all sorts of other
cell lines that people have worked on
for mammalian cells
okay thank you Stacy and before we go do
you have any final comments for our
audience today
[Music]
your time with this
is want to contact us at info biolog.com
I think this audience is very
International and we have Distributors
all over the world so just contact us at
info dialogue.com we'll put you in touch
with your distributor or your sales rep
if you're interested in a webinar for
your group we're happy to do that as
well so just definitely send us
um an email at info biolog.com and we
can discuss the specific needs that you
have
fantastic well thank you again Stacy for
your time today and your report and
research uh we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor via log for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand lab Roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you